fidanzata o no sono sposati chiamano ora
di le diavole guarda la cucina
bellissima premeva cerca praticamente
oggi mi ha fatto venire qui non ti va di
fare niente allora mi prende un po di
esposizione media girato un video che ce
l'avrei di gioco
diciamo che mi sono fatto mandare dei
nomi per giocare a bombe o la pasta non
è un gioco è un vilipendio e il corpo
delle persone
l'odio il format bombi ora pass credo
che trattare le persone come figurine
oggetti sessuali che uno può decidere di
valutare come se fosse un pezzo alla
carne sono io posso essere mercifica
orribile tu puoi essere mercificato anzi
spoiler
lo trovo diseducativo a me pedine di
parlare io non ho pensato a un bombola
passi tradizionale voglio saperlo ho
pensato un bambino una passi in
filosofico possiamo dire guarda bondiola
passi voglio vedere in che senso che io
valuterò i maschi e tu le femmine così
non c'è nessun tipo di qualità a
prontissimo tenute entro belle essere un
divertimento rai però devi essere onesto
non farm al solito to vu voglio vedè
tempi che attraverso questo sì che mi
piace sono contento che stanno facendo
così divertente anche per sottolineare
quanto è abominevole questo form che
bobbio la passino titolo osceno
pretendente una cosa no è orribile ori
fatemi sapere a parte così che è
divertente perché mi deve scegliere i
capi
io devo scegliere fra n 7 su questo e
molto fine come la metti il gesto di
base secondo me è la follia poi ditemi
voi è arrivato un messaggio al telefono
di viano rispondo la data 27 ma il
cellulare gabriele infondato toccato a
lo leggessero gabriele non puoi fare
questi gesti pronti 3 2 1 le analisi
jason momoa scusa perché io c'ho jason
momoa tu c'hai calisi a parte che i due
acqua bene in questo commento prova
parti ma che cosa aveva la crisi della
cai madre di draghi la casa dalla
tempesta vice tom baker chains la crisi
se non te la bombi tese bombate
nicoletta compatta portatile più briere
no no no mi piace come personaggio tu
hai la possibilità di gabriele la mano
la messa storta della tesi della droga e
poi anche vibrare le chiederei saliamo
sul pro drago asso e mi piace molto la
personaggio poter essere la sua migliore
amica reazione beaumont aree dice se non
lo bomb la linea mi si imponga
challenger harry potter secondo me è in
bocca ma non per i miei gusti questo
neanche sotto maledizione imperio
veramente guarda io e il miur e la bomba
è il mio personaggio preferito di
rifarmi una kia cilea no per niente
il mio la bomb è un po tipo tvb ma con
gabriele no penso e passo è la stimo
puoi anche fare così non accendo un
accenno qua guardate com'è per 3 2 1 io
no no no
non si possono perdere chiara è
adorabile ma dai non entusiasma capito
il gioco a volte che una madre di
famiglia sono sposate ma io so che
federico ce l'ho io esco usano toni
dicendo niente se mi sento spongano
sapienza per commento se non puoi fare
un commento
voglio vedere come ne esce che ne pensi
di federico per discreto carisma di
guardia che occhi chiara cioè messaggio
e lo trovo in gamba bella buona
simpatica ma non posso non posso
mettermi in mezzo alla sua storia è un
figlio bisogna stai provando è fatto
solo complimenti valenti niente noi
ferrandez di passiamo io in realtà con
chiara non vorrei essere di qom
seducente matador
io vorrei essere un iconico sono la
signora nesbitt ivo parlati e ci disse
un po di te signorina center 8 ne va ma
scommetto su tu non puoi fare commenti
su di me lo posso fare commenti su di te
ma chi me l'ha temi nascono e che non
previsto chiara ferragni che fonde il
telefono purtroppo ti devo passare per
monica marito non si mette dietro a joe
di angelina a tutti amano aspetto che
devo alzare in piedi da angelina jolie
le cose che a me piacciono di angelina
jolie nevi dire che ai ragazzi brad pitt
intramontabile se vi però della coppia
brad pitt angelina jolie nati grazie
7 non tipo di angelina mantenere allora
abbiamo le cose che mi piacciono di
angelina jolie ma è il suo impegno nel
sociale pazzesco alle una donna pazzesca
me ne frega niente del suo impegno
sociale non hai capito un cazzo guarda
ora tiriamo della parte cabriolet che
basta questa superficialità del fatto
che le persone sono solamente il loro
aspetto lei mi piace per quello che fa
ma perché mette il video così mentre
vendola di posso dire vedendo gabriele
più capace di entrare nella mentalità
omosessuale e lamentano sessuale che uno
dei più desiderati da tutte le donne
rispetto a me che cos'è che non ha
dt bellissimo quanto dice a 60 questo
quindi si angelina riponiamo poi io per
rispetto angelina un po sono lasciati
ragazzi criticatemi non brevi per chi
bomb mario breve eva kant provassi fabio
karen pochesci bel baffetto vale catore
lei
secondo me è super super super che
rinero conosciuta durante la live su
twitter di fa ma ora stanno insieme da
tanto non lo so mi potresti anche essere
l'uomo che l'ha rubata fabio ok
lei è super carina supersimpatica e
super scialla io e le ragazze molto
belle amo quando sono sciolti con
standard una bella coppia era bomboniere
ad un po fabio davanti a lui abbia
veramente io ti chiedo scusa per mio
fratello perché è veramente scherzo ma
non pensavo fosse così via uno che mi
piace fare quello che vuole
a parte gli scherzi la bomba ma bondi se
lei si fa bello il baffetto così o se
questi bello peccato che scende sulla
tua schiena di votazioni non ti paesi ma
non accetti un tuo amico tommaso zorzi
non posso fare perché per me sono due le
persone che che mi fanno simpatia che
conosco però è della rete super
divertente in gamba intelligente bravate
presenterò serena con sgombero perchè
lui c'è la sfiga quei ragazzi almeno
bomba il ragazzo sia un anatema g tu
senti le storie tom attuati sull'amore
ti metti una mano davanti una mano
dietro anch'io tommaso fortuna di eccola
vi siete trovati che hai voglia spezza
il cuore un tuo amico me lo devi stosur
nel cuore rallo lasciati andare lato
scuro asso tommasone noto milan a tema
continua io e l'aurora la prima ma non
per cantiere fidanzata felicemente
fidanzati fidanzatissimi un bellissimo
ragazzo
andiamo avanti pronti via e lei diretta
del chicca diletta leotta doppiavano
incrociata cristiano ronaldo cr7 troppo
poco sa che io passo subito non
facilissima non la conoscono le reti
carrier at è realmente quindi anche se
bella che ci facciano su diletta e
simpaticissima per amare il lavoro
la simpatica guarda che occhi da
cerbiatta ho capito canale visto bambino
piccolo mai visto bambino piccolo si è
presente un dolore la mamma ha contati
non mi piace come momento masso diletta
leotta franchi cr7 lo passo
anche perché secondo me in italy tema un
pochino di uno di quelli che quando fa
l'amore con qualcuno in realtà sta
facendo l'amore con se stesso bomber e
si e poi eccoli qua i 13 21 giorgio
americane giusto ho visto grande è stato
insieme per anna rita non solo per
fisicato lui e loro sono carinissimi lei
tra l'altro grande chef è ospite di
sfuggire culinaria non è vero forma non
capisco me però se tu mi stai vendendo a
me costitutivi fare la tua cosa stai qua
guardiamo i tuoi guarda i miei pezzi e
un'amica non mi posso maggiori io non me
la sento
credo che ci saremmo molto simpatici ma
cucina benissimo a breve per cercarne
bomb più basso una scusa perché non
perché va bene per questo non mi piace
di marchi ormai religiose fidanzato che
non posso ripassiamo lasciamoci lasciamo
la coppia felice felice pronti via
edward cullen bella swan ma si legge
kubilai khan ti deve interessare il suo
cool non è solo mio paese ragazzi seri
vigoriti dati oggettivamente bellissimo
trasforma da bombe con una dentiera il
mantello da dracula la bomboniera accade
nelle caccia a sap ag
preferisco claudio di biagio con lo
scotch ne faccia claudio 6 meglio
comunque detto fra noi lui è quello che
brilla al sole ma ci si potrebbe fare
del buon anno e di business quindi ma
diventati di amantea brilla strillone
nome non ha valore non ha valore
passo la grande muro bianco 30 o il no
mai
il molto crema si sa mai
mi sembrerebbe di farmi in parente ma è
la vita e perché frank ma mai nella vita
greco passano una foglia treno
immaginare e frank no passo passo siamo
io e frankie bomba frenò tanto è
capitato che passa a casa un caffè una
birra di troppo
io camilla mai nella vita molto carina
se lo dico con fare che può dare
ulteriore vero e fidanzata in halo è lo
sono tutti abbastanza la vita la casa i
numeri sale gabriele organi in testa io
qui sono più i video che le mani catino
e poi si trasformano mai la presa ma
volta che ci siamo baciati hanno pagato
non siamo più per cambio marra averne
proprio coppia io marra non me lo bomber
è mai perché avrei paura a me yet tutti
fanno paura e lo di no a me non mi
farebbe paura a me farebbe paura
bombardi elodie perché poi marra minimi
picchia ma tu non trovi father este e lo
dimena bomber e ma la trovo di un
talento e di un magnetismo poi sono
semplici come persone quindi con cena o
realtà a loro due secondo me se lasciamo
l'isolamento beh sì esatto perché
secondo me è lui ma come un sacco di
questi duri in realtà sul super buoni
perseo tese un sacco di iseo
io me la bomber ehi ma ho paura del
phishing onesto allora sembra polverelli
sarebbe secondo me un incontro mentale
miss mistico mesi tra tutte devo dire
che l'ho di spegnere la bomba io non
sono solo i maschi che non mi piacciono
e nel caso sarei all attivo
o devo essere quello che tra cui sente
il ricevente c'è chi può andar bene come
tipo inter pende che tu da me la faccio
tutte le ruote
marazico alla caviglia e talentuoso
fatto l'album che ti piace tanto a 321
pianore chiara ben gf di ragazzi parole
chiare possa esser sincero paoli chiara
pazzesche le bomboniere bomb no tutti
penso a benevento non vi conduca le
chiare non può quando ero bambino ams e
nazionali
ma scusa non ti piace la canzone dimmi
dove e quando questa sera tu mi stai
bomba dove durante paro in ogni bomb
però la canzone di migliore quando è
mostrare ma io parecchie rimbombo
entrambe ma sono sempre ma giovanni
agiamo le charlie's angels posso dire
cosa no tu capire tu non sei anni
bersani fanno un commento quando
giochiamo keys o maggiorenni e tu fai
due o che voglio giocare seriamente si è
divisa dovuta all emergenza sono qui a
me pare questa premessa le charlie's
angels io le amo più in particolare
proprio mii non posso dire certe cose ma
nonostante tutto le passo perché mi
pongo il trio comico aldo giovanni e
giacomo venturi che io le charlie's
angels le bombole mi sarei offeso
altrimenti piano giovanni già con
carinissimi stupendi c'è però
e qui io posso immaginare cose che non
accadranno mai li invece posso avere
un'idea 321 biala donald trump che va
bene essere soddisfatto ha già pronto
perché lui non gli puoi dire di no
questo è uno che non gli dice di no a
passo anche io ma so anche io un matto
gamma bagram a corsi a chi doveva esser
sincero al dramma è l'unico in realtà
che ho amato in tutti e due i modi
quindi tutta la vita mi funerali fanno
io bomb shampoo ma non c'è alajo bomber
yoga fa quindi ramalho bambini ma
ciascuno date luoghi della scuola fuori
in campo il carrettino 21 abbiamo né
ambra marie che sono sposati io a rosati
6 sono giovanissimi colleghi si era
scritto qualche volta su instagram è
super carino è un gamer molto molto
forte non so se forte a giocare un gamer
molto forte successo tutto prende le
pietre e le sue alcune sim palma voglia
di commentare mike vedovile oggi con lo
sguardo nel mio telefono cercando di
capire se mi sentirei in colpa si
impongono su a morire assieme essere
colpa rimasto io pure per rispetto ad
andrano
passiamo siete felici siete ragazzi
siete fantastici 15 20 venire ma non
posso passanti perdono in via tropea
poco aperto maria de filippi temi caldi
quando robbie williams ha baciato meriti
a beniamino mappa o meglio de filippi
pazzesca maria de filippi non può non
bombarda io faccio uno anzi no maria
marino e tu non troppo non è non è la
popola stessa gabriele a parte il gusto
il conte brad pitt angelina jolie e con
tema de filippi non perché ciò che cosa
anche che non c'è pieno la com
io guardo il collo prima cosa che guardo
in un uomo il corpo da maurizio una
bella bomba bombana allora sarebbe alla
fine io vorrei dire solo una cosa troppo
questo gioco orripilante ma a patto
ovviamente su delle persone delle quali
non hai un attrazione fisica
niente più divertente perché una cosa
più mentale che c'è nico facciamo una
cosa allora adesso fra tutti quelli
detti ne dovete scegliere un oro del
sesso giusto che chi butteresti se fra
tutti quelli detti posso pure il
tridente delle 102 il tridente ha preso
tre agenti che la mia è abbastanza
facile è più noti al mondo insomma moto
così chissà che ci sono tutti
l'uomo harry potter io c'ho la carissima
madre dei gracchi chi no no non devi
fare un commento su tutti
mimmo diventa la madre dei miei figli
sono un po il cane cioè le persone di
base che stavano con delle ragazze
dicevano un bellabona questa seconda
faccia da the ring follia io ho scelto
che ha scelto diletta ovviamente bomb
angelina jolie angelina può averne pure
cento è pazzesca per ragazzi bomba bliss
giorgio vanni anzi crimine dolcina
migani a è meglio dettosi a banche
volgare se questo gioco spero che venga
compreso il fatto che non l'abbiamo
fatto anche in questo momento del mese
del pride capito invertire tondo ragazzi
va beh questa nuova produzione indebita
è finita è stato un esperimento se
volete altre applicazioni indebite di
qualsiasi altro genere commentare con
momo attese bam bam a rombo bomb
commentati tutti con jason bomb noi come
sempre ragazze vi ricordo accendiamo un
martedì con un blog giovedì con un video
speciale e domenica con cucina buttata
ciao ciao che quindi porta il comunque
su mentre in questo canale iv e perdere
5 di vita perché non sono mai quali
saranno a kakà ma neanche io lo sapevo
vedere questa cornetto tette brivido per
sé proprio solo